uh yes so my understanding is I think
this bill has passed with relative ease
230 knows
289 yes
um so what we've seen today really is
not hugely surprising we thought this
bill was going to get through this
report stage in the comments of course
next it's going to be in the Lords where
I'm sure there will be plenty of views
but what has been the most interesting
thing about today really has been the
senior conservative MP after senior
conservative MP that has been damning
um in their verdict on the illegal
migration Bill people like Jeffrey Cox
um calling it a deliberate breach of
international law Ian Duncan Smith
talking about the unintended
consequences for modern slavery victims
Theresa May calling it a slap in the
face to victims of modern slavery but as
you can see there a majority of 59 there
was drama in the chamber and perhaps
unsurprising we do often see
um in these sorts of debates
conservative MPS Keen to get their views
across but in the end there weren't
actually any votes on those conservative
amendments either because deals had been
reached behind the scenes with the
government all because it seemed like
they didn't have
um the numbers so that's obviously the
politics of all of this